ich würde da die heiraten und teile ok
vögeln
ich weiß genau was in dem drin ist und
das wird so steife alter hut münchen
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem spielball stellung
wir haben solche versammelt des 1
wir haben uns gedacht wir zocken die
zocken
wir hatten erst überlegt ob wir
irgendwie vielleicht mit challenge
machen oder so aber dann hatten wir
gedacht kommen freundliche herr koch
trinkwasser oder also wir schreiben
jetzt zwei tiere zwei servet es um zwei
youtuber drei youtuber ja 32 tiere sind
fünf dann 22 gegenstände sind 67 und
dann noch mal zwei okay wir schreiben
machen denn wir machen das einfach mal
wieder das jetzt mal was halt doch ein
stift der wohnung ja ich schreibe das
blut kann denkt wie ich schreibe schon
mal einfach ne
die ebenso beschäftigen
ja meine lieben freunde nach einer sehr
langen zeit wir haben jetzt circa 13
minuten glaube ich einfach nur diese
paar teile hier fertig gekriegt das sind
jetzt einfach insgesamt sechs youtuber
vier celebrities vier gegenstände und
vier tiere richtig und wir werden jetzt
abwechseln 13 also er zieht jetzt drei
dann den ersten blick zu schicken in
denen die du kannst du gewinnen kann man
sich aussuchen ja dass er die das werden
die die wunderbare vorn wieso also das
können wir auch nicht spannender werden
wenn jetzt zwei schüler so entstand im
juli ein vögel alter ok ich hab' mir
elefanten mit schon mal ganz gut ich hab
ihn fair und ich habe mir fand und ich
hab's susan boyle die kamera wasser
gezogen ich habe ein pferd mit einem
unglaublich lang seite von luca wollen
sie möge nur in eine anstalt so zu
machen dann hat er hier
das kann nicht lesen und einen elefanten
und noch einen elefanten eigentlich denn
die richter dazu suchen wir sie töten
alte empfänger war also von daher sehe
ich töte fährt und dann haben wir aber
das problem ist also ich würde ich würde
mit susan boyle sex haben den elefanten
heiraten weil ich eher der von vögeln
finde ich ist schon echt heftig muss
sagen ich bin auch fährt vögeln heftig
ja doch irgendwann ist dann sage ich ich
heirate telefon für besuchen wollen
wenn es einen gegenstand er besitzt
hingegen steht adil lebens jubelte die
cima di sbd
wenn ich sie mal vor allem fakten wie
gehen werde ich wahrscheinlich heiraten
jamie foxx traten die wir diesmal die
töten müssen und den muss ich dann hey
das ist das sogar ab das ist jetzt sogar
nahe school immer und ich fand das sogar
ich finde das nicht so schnell wie das
montiert mit mir verheiratet alte ja ok
freunde ja nichts anderes eingefallen
echt jetzt so auf den menschen nicht
lassen deswegen sehr alte t shirt hätte
aber gerade das ist klar aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen also ich würde
natürlich den lachs töten dann würde ich
natürlich jetzt ist
ich würde ganz klar mit mit joko sex
haben
wenn wir da hast du die anderen sechs
von ihnen leben noch einmal
das ist mir wie du mich jemand nach frau
verheiratet auch wenn das ist eigentlich
will ich auch in die oper feiert sein
daher kommt und dann kann es halt immer
noch so was von anderen so weiter weil
ja genau das ist nicht hoffen
die schnauzer zeiten also jupiter
einfach nur möbel sind so der coach
aber jetzt hat ja die sind also freunde
ich habe jetzt endlich bin ich mal als
erstes hier den kleinen auf denn wir
wollen in dem kleinen steht daneben
rang vier steht teile auf lager ich
möchte teile auch echt nicht töten weil
ich den typen megamarkt eigentlich ich
respektiere hinte und er hat sogar schon
schon date mit dem präsident mit frau
mama und der erste auf jeden fall den
schrank dann ja jetzt ist die frage
ich glaube ich würde echt ich würde da
die heiraten und tyler ok vögeln lassen
wir das
dieses spiel ist kacke wollen sie davon
mehr voll
wie kommst du denn noch die beiden beste
wenn ich hier 6 julia kriege ja ich
dachte sowas was ist denn so witzig weiß
in so einem spiel das wird eine
spannende runde sache sieht sogar die ab
6 uhr an live packard und ich hoffe mal
ganz genau 6 julia ganz genau aussieht
kann so ein leichtes bildung ok ohne
spaß sowie zu den sechs schweine haben
eine kleine theoretische hatte aber ich
würde ich auch keinen vater töten da
sind so schöne tier ja ich mag einfach
aber ich glaube ich zudem alpaka auch
nichts gutes und dann sex mit ihm hatte
welche verbände mit julia und sex haben
und heiraten obwohl jedoch ruhig nehmen
die erst ab april wird werden exakt
julias amme tischbein muss getöteten
objekte direkt unterstellt ist eine
waffe ich weiß genau was in dem drin ist
und das wird so scheiße aus weiler
das ist geil eine sache und jetzt kam
spielt jetzt auf die richtige spur
jawohl ich habe eine waffe nach biel und
malta lukas podolski sind die waffen von
den menschen töten aber da ist ja ein
spiel ist und man das konzert musste
sich lukas podolski zu heiraten so einer
weil ich die mega gern kpmg
ich weiß nicht wie ich und die wache
die fortschritte von dem video findet
ihr dann auf einem anderen gerät freuen
wir uns jetzt gedanken einer weiteren am
ende und zwar hier noch mal die ganzen
sachen drin gelegen alle falsch rum und
wir müssen uns jetzt jeder einging davon
rausziehen ohne hinzuschauen und das
müssen wir so wie htc und das müssen wir
jetzt gleich also jetzt nicht gleich für
hielt aber das wissen wir auch man schon
wieder
es ist doch nicht wahr wie frogster
befreundet das war's in diesem video
haben wir nehmen einfach mal diese
fakten challenge auch wenn ihr mehr
ideen habe für so was in die richtung
und challenges oder irgendwie weiter
wenn es euch gefallen hat könnte es
gerne die kommentare schreiben eine
bewertung das einstiegsgehalt ist der
beschreibung verlinkt und wir sehen uns
in deinem nächsten video wieder
meine finger verdeckt nicht komplett das
ding muss zunehmen